blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman i want to start today with
something that really shouldn't be
notable it shouldn't be news it
shouldn't be remarkable it shouldn't be
something where we would say wow look at
that
but it is notable because of the way in
which the republican party since the
2020 election has either outright said
joe biden didn't really win this
election or publicly played coy with it
saying we should investigate all claims
of voter fraud we should want to verify
we should be able to verify that the
election wasn't rigged kind of playing
coy with it now you might remember that
republican congressman adam kinzinger
said and we played the clip a couple
weeks ago
no none of us no republicans really
believe that donald trump won the
election other than maybe a couple
whether he's signaling to people like
marjorie taylor green or whoever by
saying a couple but the point was adam
kinzinger said whatever most republicans
are saying publicly
privately we know that joe biden
actually won this election
lauren windsor uh former guest on the
david pakman show from the undercurrent
she does she really does a good job with
this type of thing
um she confronted
wisconsin republican senator ron johnson
but confronted him not as someone saying
you've been spreading lies but
confronted him as someone pretending to
believe that donald trump actually did
win the election and that donald trump
actually did win the state of wisconsin
and we're gonna look at the video and
it's very good here's a sort of summary
from the daily beast senator ron johnson
caught on hidden camera blaming trump
for the 2020 defeat wow why is that even
a headline it's a headline because
they've been pretending that trump
actually won
um we're gonna look at the video here's
a screenshot of it for people who are
watching with us today
um after he uh
let's actually let's look at the video
first and then discuss more so again
this is lauren windsor uh going to ron
johnson and pretending to be an unhinged
uh right winger who believes that joe
biden didn't really win the election
let's listen
you can't even state
even throwing in that there was a vote
dump i mean even that is pretty pretty
slickly done because that's a term trump
used massive dumps of votes
that this is really well done by lauren
i don't remember exactly
we've done a recount
priority prior to this election i was
the number one vote getter statewide
just under 1.5 million votes okay
this election trump got a million six
ten no we're gonna ever crack 1.5
million he said no numerous
democrats have gone over 1.6 or 1.5
so now for the first time in history we
have across this candidate
beating my vote total by 130 000 votes
collectively
the state assembly candidates and
what's notable about this is not only is
ron johnson clearly sure that donald
trump didn't win
he actually knows historical
mathematical context and uh it's just a
reinforcement of the fact that adam
kinzinger clearly is right 99 of these
guys and gals they know all the voter
fraud stuff is bs
661.
the eight congressional candidates also
got a million
so we obviously counted enough
republican votes
this is as clear as it can be so
understand the point that uh johnson's
making here is this is almost the point
i made when i tweeted
if they believe that the results for the
presidential are wrong then the results
for their own congressional and senate
races must also be wrong right and ron
johnson is saying listen the numbers for
the for state reps and all these other
races the numbers are coherent the
numbers make sense
and trump just lost because 51 000
republicans didn't vote for him it's
very simple
a little more here you're telling me
that joe biden won the statement
the governor the announcement
because i don't see it i don't believe
it
it's certainly plausible there's nothing
obviously there's nothing obviously
skewed about the results okay
[Applause]
wisconsin no i'm not saying what's
happening
i don't know the same candidates
collect collectively wisconsin and
georgia and arizona listen
republican visibly frustrated by people
who insist trump actually won
collectively republicans got
1.661 million votes 51 000 more votes
so it's a very simple case
the margin was only 20 000 in wisconsin
all of the numbers make sense in
congressional races in state races etc
but there were 51 000 republicans a
small slice that didn't vote trump
because they didn't like trump or they
didn't want to vote for trump for
whatever the case may be and that's more
than the margin of victory for joe biden
that's it that's all it is and uh this
is exactly what adam kinzinger told us
these guys don't really believe that
trump won
uh i i mean am i sort of surprised ron
johnson didn't blame antifa yeah maybe
um but it's actually not that you know
in these one-on-one conversations they
will sometimes or what they believe are
one-on-one conversations they will
sometimes tell what is actually the
truth
as soon as you get two people there or
you get a room full of of republicans
for a q a town hall
it's time for the whole song and dance
and well listen what i know is there are
people who claim that their votes
weren't counted correctly and we should
be able to investigate all of that and
that let the results fall come on dude
he knows it and most of these people uh
know it and really nice job there by
lauren windsor
all right joe rogan joe rogan podcast
host joe rogan is positive for covid and
he is taking like seven different drugs
and treatments including ivermectin a
horse dewormer and anti-parasitic in
some doses for humans okay all right
we'll talk about that
this is notable for a couple of
different reasons first uh actually
maybe we'll look at the video clip first
but to set the stage
this is the same joe rogan yeah on whose
show i've appeared twice and i don't but
he he may never have me back on because
i've been critical of the things he said
about coveting vaccines this is the same
joe rogan who said if you're healthy and
your eat right like he does
you don't need to be vaccinated um let's
look at the video clip of joe rogan
explaining what happened listen to the
list of medications and treatments that
he's on
and then there's there's much to discuss
here
hello friends
so i got back from the road saturday
night
feeling very weary i had a headache and
i just felt just run down and
just to be cautious
i separated from my family slept in a
different part of the house
and throughout the night i got fevers
and sweats and i knew what was going on
so
i got up in the morning got tested
and turns out i got covered so we
immediately threw the kitchen sink at it
all kinds of meds monoclonal antibodies
uh ivermectin
cpac
prednisone
everything
and i also got an nad drip and a vitamin
drip and i did that three days in a row
and so
here we are on wednesday
and i feel great i really only had one
bad day sunday sucked but monday was
better
tuesday felt better than monday and
today i feel good i actually feel pretty
[ __ ] good
uh that's the good news the bad news is
we have to move friday
the friday show in nashville okay so um
there's a bunch of stuff that is
important to talk about here now again
people have been every time i talk about
joe rogan and the vaccine stuff or
whatever people write to me and say
david i thought you were friends with
joe i've been on joe's show twice we've
corresponded via twitter a few times i
would be i would say any of this to joe
um and there this is not like some hot
take down i'm going to tell you what i
think kind of doesn't make sense about
all of this there's the macro and
there's the micro okay
the big picture story from from rogan
has been this is not serious enough
where young healthy people should really
go and get vaccinated it doesn't make
sense
um
in an in a p what's interesting is way
back when i i was last on with joe he
said he did think wearing masks outdoors
made sense even though i was kind of
saying at the time i'm not really sure
about that
more recently with bill burr he said
masks outside are you wearing a mask
outside sort of like that doesn't make
sense um he talked about how this is not
something that is serious enough
that if you are not an at-risk
individual if you're if you're healthy
and eating right or whatever you don't
really need to be vaccinated now that
immediately raises the question
as a healthy person who eats right and
stays fit
why then did joe rogan need seven
medications and treatments or fi five or
six medications and treatments including
things that aren't actually approved by
the fda either at all other outside of
emergency use
or aren't approved by the fda for covid
um that is you know the joe rogan's
argument was no vaccine for a lot of
people because the benefits don't
outweigh the risks covet isn't that
serious healthy people work out eat
right but then you're throwing the
kitchen sink at it that doesn't really
make sense you don't need the vaccine if
rogan really didn't get it i'm taking
him at his word that he didn't get it
you know we hear about people who are
secretly vaccinated i have no reason to
believe that joe rogan would do that
there are some right-wing hosts who we
later found out or right-wing
politicians i believe rogan hasn't
gotten the vaccine uh but then you're
throwing the kitchen sink at it and it's
important also to understand
we're gonna go through the medications
a lot of people wouldn't have access or
wouldn't be able to afford all of this
stuff either so there were there are
some people who are hearing this and
they're saying look rogan was right he
had one bad day
he's not vaccinated and now he's fine of
course that's to some degree chance
but also
we'll talk about the nad drips and
vitamin drips and all these things
whether or not those things do anything
if you believe that they do
a lot of that stuff's not covered by
insurance and the average person can't
handle that the vaccine is free it's
important to remember that now let's go
to the micro okay
so rogan says he took monoclonal
antibodies
that is only approved via emergency use
authorization it's available relatively
widely but remember that the pfizer
vaccine
is fully approved by the fda
uh and and same as moderna which is only
approved by emergency use for now
although in a couple of weeks it will
likely be fully approved the use of
monoclonal antibodies is experimental in
the same sense that they've been saying
the vaccine is so number one on the list
is something that's only approved by eua
so i'm not sure why someone would
hesitate on the vaccine over lack of
approval but then go and take the
monoclonal antibodies that's a hypocrisy
i'm not saying it's rogan's hypocrisy
but for people who are saying the the
antibodies are available that's as
experimental as all the vaccine were up
until 10 days ago
and now pfizer is actually approved to a
more strict level now then there's
ivermectin
ivermectin is a frequently used cattle
uh medication uh it is sometimes used in
humans as well there's no denying that
in different doses
as of a few days ago the big paper that
a lot of people were pointing to to say
ivermectin works for covid it's based on
egyptian data that was retracted why
they didn't have a proper placebo group
that the egyptian paper a lot of people
point to
was ivermectin versus hydroxychloroquine
not ivermectin versus placebo the way
you're supposed to do it in a
double-blind randomized controlled trial
then a group called the cochrane
collaboration
looked at all of the meta-analyses of
the clinical trials on ivermectin they
found that a bunch of the individual
studies had problems just like the
egyptian one
and once you look at just the studies
that are done correctly they say there
is very low to low certainty evidence
that ivermectin is at all effective on
covid19
okay world health organization
infectious disease society of america
even the manufacturer of ivermectin
merck say there is no meaningful
evidence for clinical uh efficacy
in covet 19 with ivermectin last week
the fda started warning people don't go
and get ivermectin for kovat19 and now
the american medical association is
asking doctors do not give anybody
ivermectin for covid19 so
that's the second thing that rogan is
taking importantly not approved even
under emergency use authorization for
covid the pfizer vaccine is fully
approved
lastly real quick before we move on
how do how do people start trying
ivermectin and stuff like
hydroxychloroquine the the basics are at
the beginning of all this
when we didn't have a treatment we
didn't have vaccines um doctors in
different parts of the world started
trying cheap stuff that's just around
hydroxychloroquine has been around a
really long time and it's very cheap
ivermectin is very very cheap so they
start trying it and if you
have small cohorts of 20 30 patients
and most people recover from covet
anyway you're likely to get what is some
apparent efficacy signal if you just
have a bunch of random doctors saying
here i'm going to give 30 of my patients
ivermectin or i'm going to give 30 of my
patients hydroxychloroquine by chance
you might get what appears to be an
efficacy signal
and you're just throwing this stuff at
it because it's cheap and available but
that's not how we actually do science
okay so that's ivermectin zpac this is
the antibiotic azithromycin now you
would say why would you take an
antibiotic for something that's a virus
and you would be right there are some
ideas that certain antibiotics could
have an antiviral effect against some
viruses it's been studied with covid and
azithromycin it doesn't appear to be the
case uh study looked at a single dose of
azithromycin and it didn't change the
proportion of covid patients who were
symptom-free versus symptomatic after 14
days now you might say well david why
are they only getting one dose
typically azithromycin is given you know
as a course of treatment another study
um looked at intravenous azithromycin 10
doses over 10 days
it also didn't statistically improve uh
outcomes okay so that's the third thing
rogan is taking fourth prednisone
prednisone is one of many steroids and
remember that there was the discussion
of dexamethasone for covid earlier into
pandemic this is a very basic idea this
is the idea that steroids can mitigate
the inflammatory response and that
inflammatory response can lead to lung
injury in covid so you give the steroid
it reduces the inflammatory response in
the lungs maybe it helps people recover
maybe it helps people just feel better
in the short run that's generally
connected to reality if you have
inflammation you look at using a steroid
but
unless you're actually having lung
compromise it's really not clear that it
makes sense to take steroids it can have
nasty side effects it can actually make
you worse with some respiratory viruses
in previous outbreaks of novel
coronavirus infections like mers the
middle east respiratory syndrome or sars
corticosteroid therapy sometimes
actually extended how long people had
the virus in their system so it's really
unclear um and uh they're so so that's
kind of like a question mark we don't
know how involved rogan's lungs were
it may have made sense to try throwing a
steroid at it or maybe not the other
stuff isn't really even medication the
nad drip that's a nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide
they it's very in vogue right now to do
these drips it's there's no indication
it helps with covid same thing with iv
vitamins it's very popular for wealthy
folks to start getting these iv drips i
know people who do it there's no reason
to think that it helps with covet now
then there's the the the final thing
here
if this stuff works okay let's just
imagine all this stuff works
kobe must be pretty freaking serious to
throw all of this stuff at it and what i
mean by that is if covet weren't serious
if covid were just the flu
then you wouldn't if you were joe rogan
be taking mono monoclonal antibodies
ivermectin antibiotics steroids vitamins
and an nad iv
three days in a row
that's pretty serious right do you
really want to take all that stuff each
with its own side effect risk
if covit isn't that serious for someone
who eats right or works out or is
generally healthy that's completely
incongruous and with the flu you don't
go and take seven medications and
treatments so
that's the real important takeaway here
i would love to talk to rogan about this
he may have seen my last clips about him
and decided i'm not having david pakman
on anymore he may not even be aware of
the clips i have no idea but i welcome
the opportunity to talk to him about it
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video all right
let me not waste time because we have so
many things to talk about and jump right
into this next story um this is an
interesting sort of glimpse into the
mind of those who are talking about
impeaching joe biden we've seen
radical members of congress like
marjorie taylor greene as well as lauren
bobert and others talk about i have
filed articles of impeachment against
joe biden i plan to impeach joe biden if
we take the house we're going to impeach
joe biden etc and aside from the fact
that there's no reason
to justify an impeachment of joe bide
there's no justification for impeaching
joe biden
one of the things i've mentioned is if
you impeach joe biden kamala harris
becomes president of the united states
is that is that really what they want to
achieve
um and if you impeach kamal harris then
nancy pelosi becomes president of the
united states unless you impeach biden
and harris and get them convicted and
removed after taking control of the
house in which case the republican
speaker of the house would become
president of the united states to his
credit a right-wing radio host glenn
beck actually confronted republican
congresswoman lauren lauren beaubert
with this and said well but if you
impeach biden then it goes to harris
does that really make sense is that
really what you want and listen to the
level of delusion
with which lauren bobert responded to
this accurate
um uh
issue
with lauren bobert's plan let's listen
together
out kamala harris as president
does it get any better right uh so of
course that is uh the number one
question when you start thinking about
impeachment and and discussing that you
start going down the list well do we
really want president harris do we
really want president pelosi um she
certainly has uh shown what she does
with the people's house here in
washington dc i can't imagine what she
would do with the white house okay so
what's the plan lauren tell us listen to
this so i have legislation uh that will
be introduced uh in impeaching both
biden and harris and nancy pelosi can
follow them out the freaking door um she
certainly needs to be held accountable
for this as well and we have called as
uh the freedom caucus we have called on
leader mccarthy um to introduce a a
resolution to vacate the chair
okay
they don't control the house of
representatives oh there might be a few
more seconds here
holy cow yeah oh so even glenn beck is
surprised by the level of stupidity of
this
so of course not so there's 99 of this
is gutter trash
one percent of it is something we
actually need to be aware of so okay
what's the gutter trash the gutter trash
is
if the
assuming that for as long as they don't
control the house or the senate
this is all just idiocy
you're not impeaching joe biden
you're not impeaching joe biden together
with kamala harris
kevin mccarthy is not you know he can
introduce whatever he wants to vacate
the speakership and take it from nancy
pelosi
none of it none of it is happening
even if they take control of the house
in 2022 and somehow they managed to
actually quote impeach which remember
the house files the articles then you
have a trial in the senate even if they
manage to do it
the senate is not going to convict on
the basis of what's happened so far the
senate is not going to convict joe biden
the senate is not going to convict
kamala here so 99 of this is just
nonsense and delusions and it shows us
how delusional she is but
i think it is almost certain
that if republicans do take control of
the house in november of 2022 just 14
months from now well the election is in
14 months taking over would be in 16 and
a half months
i think they absolutely uh impeach joe
biden i think that there is no question
that these republicans are furious about
the fact that donald trump was impeached
twice for things he deserved to be
impeached for and they are determined to
impeach joe biden so the plan of
impeachment might work if they get the
majority in 22
no senate is going to actually convict
joe biden based on what he's done so far
certainly not kamala harris either and
the idea of when you're in the minority
vacating the chair it's just absolutely
delusional but good for glenn beck for
confronting her about it i'm glad that
he did
a candace owens
has been refused a covid test because
the
operator of an independent covid testing
clinic said you're not getting a test
here because you've been a purveyor of
coveted disinformation and immediately
uh candace owens says is this woman
racist now why is this interesting this
is interesting because candace owens has
been
uh a very popular voice on the right as
a black conservative supposedly you know
it actually seems this all might be a
character a grift to make money but
let's let's imagine that it's real and
candice owens has been a loud voice
saying all of this stuff about systemic
racism all of this stuff about the right
being racist the real problem she has
said over the years
is that the left so quickly goes to
assuming anything they don't like is
racist
i'm going to play a video for you here
in which candice owens immediately says
maybe the woman denying me a kova test
is racist okay so she's doing it before
getting into that i want to mention
there's been a small controversy over
the last few days with candace owens
where she had to cancel an event because
she was suddenly ill
but has been insisting that it's not
coronavirus
and yet here she is talking about how
she's actually been seeking a
coronavirus test
which obviously raises questions about
why if you definitely don't have the
virus why are you getting tested for the
virus but she was denied a coveted test
we will look at why in a moment and here
she is immediately saying maybe the
woman denying me the test is racist i
thought candace we weren't supposed to
immediately say the motivation must be
racism for something that we don't like
take a look this thing maybe kobe's
racist maybe susanna's racist i don't
freaking know i don't know the last time
is the woman who denied her the test the
democrat refused the black person
service and said it's because i don't
like your thoughts and ideas we were in
the jim crow era but here we are
and we're actually in aspen colorado and
susanna wants to know that she will
google you this virus is not political
but she's googling people that are
signing up for tests to make sure that
their politics align with susannas can
you imagine like
yeah well okay so
dear god um
so so the the the argument here that uh
candace is making is
it's conceivable that i was denied a
cova test because
susannah is racist now here's the email
that was sent from susanna
to candace subject appointment
cancellation notice i've just learned of
this testing request and as the owner of
this business i'm going to refuse this
booking and deny service
whoa wait a second
isn't this what conservatives want
a business owner to decide who do i want
to serve and who don't i want to serve
susannah wrote we cannot support anyone
who has proactively worked to make this
pandemic worse by spreading
misinformation politicizing and
discouraging the wearing of masks and
actively dissuading people from
receiving life-saving vaccinations
candace owens has done all that that's
accurate
the only other local testing option is
the free kiosk by city hall they mail
their tests to texas and have
inconsistent result times do not take
appointments so it's walk in only midday
weekdays in their back alley my team and
myself have worked overtime to
exhaustion unpaid and underpaid this
last year spending our own capital to
ensure our community remains protective
it would be unfair to them and to the
sacrifices we have all made this year to
serve you susanna that is the free
market of ideas that candace owens
supposedly
um supports
and it is a business owner deciding what
is best for themselves and even though
candace owens has made money for years
and years saying look at all these
democrats immediately finding racism the
racism is seeing the racism
and yet in the first five seconds she
says
maybe susanna herself is racist what a
pathetic
hypocrite and remember it's almost
certainly all a grift we'll have more on
this on our instagram find us there at
david pakman show
find me on instagram david.pacman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
it's great to welcome to the program
today vincent raccanello who is a
virology professor at columbia
university and also host of the podcast
this week in virology um it's so great
to have you on today i appreciate it
my pleasure glad i could make it after
all that rain yesterday yeah i saw the
videos it's some something else
um listen i'll just jump into some
things because there are maybe some
specific things that that are new ground
for my audience that i think might be
interesting to talk about and i think
it'll it'll open up a broader discussion
with something like the idea that um
there's a period of time during which
you can be incubating this virus in
other words you you have been infected
you don't yet have symptoms you would
not yet test positive if you were to be
tested
what is actually happening during that
period of time is it that there are some
virus particles in you but they've not
established themselves in your system
like what is taking place at that point
so let's think when you get infected
you're typically inhaling
droplets that have been produced by
someone else right they're infected
their droplets have virus you inhale
them into your nose typically they go
into the cells lining
your nose and further back which we call
the nasopharynx and the viruses then
attach to cells
it's not easy to do that that's why a
lot of viruses have to get in you to
start an infection but the virus is
attached to cells they're taken into the
cells and then they begin to multiply
and in the very first hours
it's very low levels the viruses are in
maybe a few cells
they're beginning to multiply you can't
really detect it by pcr but then you go
above a threshold where those cells
produce virus the virus infects
neighboring cells and it goes on and on
maybe it takes about 20 hours for a
cycle to complete in a cell so after a
few days you are now at the point where
you would test positive by pcr so in
that interval that you're interested in
the virus is multiplying your your
immune system is beginning to detect it
you have the earliest immune system
which is called innate immunity can
detect what's going on there and in fact
most infections are stopped very early
on before they progress any farther
but then
if the innate immune system doesn't work
and part of that is interferons which
you may have heard about which block
virus infections in many ways if the
innate immune system doesn't work the
virus keeps multiplying and then we have
activation of other immune systems which
include antibodies and t cells and then
it becomes a race to see if the virus
can outpace it and then after a certain
number of days
maybe five days on average you might
then feel symptoms you might get a
scratchy throat you might get a headache
you might get a fever and so forth which
might prompt you to go get tested and
bingo there you go you you get a pcr
test and you're positive i have um
friends who have gotten a bunch of the
abbott
home tests
and for example a friend had a birthday
party with 10 people last week and of
course everyone had to be vaccinated but
he also tested everybody on the way in
and his belief was
if there was a negative from someone who
was in this state you and i just
described the virus has entered their
body but they they are not yet testing
positive that it's okay because they are
almost certainly not contagious at that
point is is that actually our best
assessment of one's uh level of con of
how contagious you are during that
intervening period
yes the pcr tests are very sensitive
so if if they are picking up nucleic
acid you have a good amount of viral
multiplication and if you're negative on
this test and you go to an affair for a
couple of hours certainly in the time of
that you're not going to change from
non-infectious to being infectious so if
you're negative
i would say you have 24-hour window
before you might even start shedding
virus and infecting others
when it comes to
the conversation of variants
i've read a number of pieces that say
that evolutionarily the way that there
is selection pressure on these variants
the idea of a significantly more deadly
variant becoming dominant is not
particularly likely i know that there's
a lot in there about level of
infectivity versus
the the the deadly nature and a lot of
things to unpack but let's start with is
it true that it is unlikely that a much
more deadly strain would become dominant
if so why if not why not
when we look at all the viral outbreaks
in humans over the years for the most
part viruses do not become more deadly
if anything over a long period they
become
less deadly they become better adapted
to their hosts and i'm talking many many
years maybe hundreds of years in time
and so there's no there's no
evolutionary reason why a virus would
become more deadly
because it would kill its host faster
and it would be less likely to transmit
and transmission transmission of course
is the raison d'etre for a virus so
the variants are certainly arising
because of some kind of selection
pressure right we think part of it is
immunity in the population we didn't see
these variants until
late in 2020 when a lot of people
globally had already been infected or
vaccinated and had some kind of immunity
so antibodies can certainly put pressure
on a virus
so that you would select a virus that is
slightly different and can evade the
antibody it happens with influenza virus
every year and there are probably other
selection mechanisms that we don't know
about because these variants have a lot
of different changes so i think in the
end what we can say about the variants
they're selected probably mainly because
of immune pressure they're not likely to
be more deadly even though there's some
studies here and there that suggest that
they're not very well done they're not
very well controlled i think the main
issue is
is immunity and escape from it and over
a period of time would we or let me put
it a different way there is already a
trial going on
with a modified mrna vaccine tailored to
more recent variants i don't know the
exact timeline of when that may become
the one that you get when you go to cvs
or walgreens or wherever the case may be
is it likely that like the flu shot we
would need to be tailoring the vaccine
to the most recent variants
it's certainly possible now with
influenza that can happen every year or
two right we tailor a new vaccine and we
have so much experience with influenza
that we know
when antibody levels drop below a
certain point in people we know that
correlates with them getting more severe
disease we don't have that infra
information yet for source cov2 we don't
know what antibody levels are protective
we don't know how low you can go and
still be protected from disease right
now
the vaccines protect against severe
disease and death even though antibody
levels are declining so it's not clear
if when we would need to change the
vaccine i think we have to wait and see
if more and more vaccinated people this
is the key
do fully vaccinated people start to get
more sick do they get severe disease do
they die when we reach that point then
we talk about
changing the virus vaccine earlier on um
there was the
idea that was much repeated i guess we
would call it a belief that the two-dose
regimen of either the pfizer or moderna
vaccine
would likely be good for at least a year
there were discussions of two to three
years etc more recently there's been the
the data from israel that shows that the
antibody levels although as you say we
don't know exactly what that means in
the real world but antibody levels seem
to start declining after eight months
there's the idea maybe after six months
one would get a third dose i've also
read some
uh doctors say the third dose will
almost certainly be the last one at this
point it seems to me we really just
don't know we really just can't say
three is going to be it what is it that
we need to be looking at to really get
an answer to that question
so one thing we have to understand is
that with every human viral vaccine you
get vaccinated six to eight months later
your antibody levels decline it's the
natural process there's nothing new
about sarsko v2 vaccines and antibodies
declining i mean although people are
making it out to be a big deal okay they
are declining and
with that there has been a push for
boosters what's not declining though is
protection against
severe disease and death that remains
robust so the antibodies level decline
you may get infected even if you're
fully vaccinated but that happens with
just about every other human viral
vaccine that we know about but you don't
get serious disease that's how we tested
these vaccines to prevent covid of any
kind now we're getting mild covet even
after fully vaccinated and so the key
for a booster so i think the booster
idea is somewhat flawed because the idea
is to push antibody levels up again but
they're going to decline in six to eight
months so are we going to go every year
and give people a booster i don't think
that's a good public health strategy
frankly
the key is do we still prevent severe
disease and death so far we are doing
that and as long as that protection
remains strong then i don't think we
need to have a booster and to think that
it would be the last one well there's
simply no data to suggest that i think
that would be great if it were but we
simply don't know when it comes to the
seasonality of this
when we were going into last fall
there was generally speaking a consensus
that we were going to see a big increase
and the
the explanations vary depending on what
what you looked at a part of it was
similar explanation with influenza that
as it gets colder people spend more time
inside and that that's going going to
increase transmission we were not yet
vaccinating at that time uh this fall
we seem to be seeing at least the growth
of cases slow down it's not yet
declining but if we're six to eight
weeks after where europe is maybe we are
starting to get to a peak so maybe we
won't see that increase into fall and
winter although maybe we will what's our
best assessment right now as to the see
the quote seasonality of this and what
is actually the source of that what what
generates that
so we really don't know
how seasonal kovit is right because it's
brand new and when you have a pandemic
that trumps all seasonality effects so
for example in 2009 the pandemic
influenza virus emerged in august which
is totally weird because they usually
come out in in the winter but when
there's a pandemic most people are not
immune so the virus can spread even
though it's the wrong season so that's
what we're seeing
with source cov2 now there are other
coronaviruses that infect us they cause
common colds there are four different
ones they are seasonal and it's likely
just by extension that sars cov2 will be
seasonal as well although still we're in
this pandemic phase where seasonality
gets trumped by simply if you have a lot
of susceptible people around which we
still do uh the virus will reproduce
whenever it wants to
what is the actual mechanism for the
seasonality is it as simple as the
temperature forces people indoors and
increases spread
well that's a good question because it
you know seasonality is different for
different viruses in the heyday of polio
in the in the world
that was one that spread in the summer
right warm weather when kids were out
playing and so forth but influenza is in
the winter in uh seasonal and temperate
climates and we think that's because the
low temperature allows the virus to
remain infectious longer and the low
humidity keeps those droplets that you
exhale keep that keeps them very small
because in humid conditions they take on
water they drop to the ground more
quickly when it's dry they can travel
farther and infect people but we we
don't know much about that for most
other viruses it's a really tough topic
to understand
so i know how to frame my next question
have you seen the mask efficacy study
from bangladeshi data
i have not you haven't okay tell me
so i'll
my understanding of the bangladeshi
study on on mask efficacy is that
for older cohorts there was definitively
reduced transmission from mask wearing
although the statistical significance of
the reduction seemed to be lower the
younger the cohort you looked at there
may be other confounding factors there
so you know i think that the devil is
probably in the details what's our best
assessment right now
of the impact of masks on reducing
spread because it's become very
politicized and controversial and maybe
the science doesn't suggest it should be
yeah so masking is tough because it's
hard to do a good study right you would
love to be able to take a group of
people with masks and without and
challenge them with virus and see the
mask but we just can't do that
so we have to use surrogates and so i
think the best estimate for for covid is
that when worn properly and that's a big
if because not everyone wears them
properly and i see more and more people
just having them below their nose
because they're they're so used to it
maybe it stops 60
of transmission and it makes sense
because the droplets that carry the
virus they get caught up in the mass
material it's not the virus that gets
trapped it's the droplets carrying the
virus so if you wear them properly so
there are no gaps maybe sixty percent
it's not going to be a hundred percent
ever and we know that in many countries
where they use masks
quite often in respiratory virus season
it does make an impact so my view is
that it's an easy thing to do it's not
too much of an inconvenience i'm used to
it by now so i don't really see the
issue let's pause our conversation with
host of this week in virology vincent
racinello there on the podcast the tv
show the radio show the full
conversation is going to be posted to
our youtube channel at youtube.com slash
the david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow so even though the prior
president donald trump was one of the
most
authoritarian leaning dictator wannabe
presidents that we've had
in the modern political era
there are people on the right and this
includes republican elected officials
and this includes some people in
right-wing media who want you to believe
that it is joe biden who is about to
imprison people
force people to do this or to do that
regulate people into oblivion things
that joe biden has actually shown no
interest in doing
um and one such example of this came to
us from fox news a couple days ago
where geraldo rivera was hosting um
something on on fox news and he
interviewed fox and friends uh i guess
weekend host will kane will kane is not
like part of the big three hosts of the
weekday fox and friends but i guess he
must be a weekend guy or a fill-in guy
and will kane showed up and said that
soon
americans who were not vaccinated
against covet 19 are going to be put in
camp sort of like concentration camps
fema camps remember fema camps when
barack obama was president was a big
thing
and this was all part of being against
masks and being against vaccines and all
of these other things so let's listen to
this together and see if there's any
evidence presented actually welcome back
as covid cases rage in several locations
across the country the cdc telling
unvaccinated people not to travel over
this labor day weekend with cnn's don
lemon going even further pointing this
scolding message to those who still
refuse to get the shot
some people who are so selfish are
saying it's my freedom and i don't want
to get vaccinated i want to do that okay
fine
but think about someone other than
yourself and if you don't believe that
covet is real and that can it can affect
your health and possibly take your life
don't go to the hospital then
when you get sick
don't go to the hospital if you get sick
that's a little harsh digging but
isn't it isn't it logical a little to
say that uh you know vaccination plus
mass equals travel
unvaccinated uh you know
isn't it prudent they don't even know
what they're talking about for
unvaccinated people not to travel
i would if i wasn't vaccinated i think
this is a personal choice if i wasn't
vaccinated then i well i'm a hermit i
might just stay i might stay at home but
that is a personal choice
unvaccinated people to vaccinate people
if you got the shot you should be fine
but i want to explain really great
medical analysis here expose and i'm
actually not going to steal this from
greg because i know greg has has talked
about this before but this exposes the
combination of like dumbassery and
cruelty by don lemon because i is he
he's literally saying if you smoked and
you get lung cancer you don't get any
treatment if you didn't wear if you
didn't wear sunscreen you have melanoma
you don't get cancer treatment you ate
too many cheeseburgers no open heart
surgery if you use so that's
again he's too stupid to be on tv but
he's perfect for cnn
but there's two things going on here
will and i know how deeply you feel
about this yeah there's the
premise that unvaccinated people should
not travel
because of the risk the exponential risk
they pose to people
or children for example
and the other thing is the cruelty of
the of the you know the cavalier uh well
don't go to the hospital then if you if
you were that arrogant everybody sort of
seems confused on this segment if you
can't tell fascinated but in terms of
the first the you know the cdc is
advising people if you unvaccinate don't
travel so let me work that backwards um
regarding the second point you made
whether or not it's cruel daigon's
exactly right we're veering dangerously
close to exterminationist language what
wide extermination
otherwise examinations absolutely that's
the that's the next step putting putting
the unvaccinated into someplace else
camps whatever it may be when you listen
to the cruelty of don lemon what is will
talking about the the unvaccinated are
more likely
to end up dead in the morgue from covid
than they are to end up in some kind of
camp for the unvaccinated this reminds
me of you know like in high school
in college there there was always some
kind of know-it-all
who would have an epiphany of some kind
and they would they would rant
and nobody really wants to argue with
them so you just kind of go hmm
okay all right moving on
um that camps and exterminationism
that's what will kane is uh making me
think of here and remember that the
predictions that they're gonna end up in
camps
have been going on for a long time when
democrats have been president remember
under obama there were going to be fema
camps and people were going to be sent
to fema camps re-education camps et
cetera it didn't happen it's just par
for the course when a democrat is in the
white house now meanwhile tucker carlson
uh claims that the left just wants to
kill unvaccinated people and his guest
uh teddy daniels
who's a former officer
pro-trump military veteran running for
something i think
uh agrees here is the left wants to kill
the unvaccinated no the vaccines are
supposed to save people guys yeah this
is still america tucker okay
if
if you want to wear a mask wear a mask
yeah if
if i if you don't want to wear a mask
don't wear a mask that's what makes this
country great with the vaccines
if you've had that conversation with
your doctor and you feel a vaccine is
the best route for you
go for it
cool
but for those that don't
that's also cool
you know let people live their lives
wait but shouldn't we kill people who
don't get the vaccine well that's what
the left wants to do yeah i've noticed
you know
what
what
do people watch this stuff and believe
it i think to some degree they must
the left wants to
put into camps the unvaccinated the left
ones that kill the unvaccinated and the
problem is
that this stuff has worked to weaponize
disinformation
anti-science beliefs
in a way that is preventing us from
actually dealing with the pandemic the
way we could delta has been a problem
essentially everywhere but there are
countries that have dealt with it far
better
countries that have higher vaccination
rates countries where people are
actually following the medical
guidelines and they have turned it not
just into
medical guidelines they have turned it
into a political battle that they assess
to be life and death along the wrong
lines it is in a sense life life or
death right i mean we we know that your
likelihood of getting really sick from
covet is way lower if you're vaccinated
we know that your likelihood of dying
from covet is way lower if you're
vaccinated it is life or death but
they've got a completely different life
or death sort of battle line drawn um
and it's unfortunately worked really
really well at convincing a lot of
different people hey this next story i i
don't even fully understand this story
i'm hoping we can try to figure it out
together
there's a pro-trump election clerk named
tina peters
accused of not counting ballots in some
local races so like this would be actual
election fraud carried out as pro-trump
election fraud it's being investigated
she is reportedly now being hidden
by
my pillow ceo mike lindell
there's a story in the daily beast about
it
and um the article explains that
during peter's first year as clerk in
mesa county
in 2019 her office was blamed for
leaving more than 570 uncounted ballots
in a box long past an election they just
didn't count him
less than a year later one of her
office's drop boxes leaked ballots
sending some floating in the summer
breeze like i'm not talking about a
metaphorical leaked that they they just
got caught in the wind the ballots were
floating around in the air okay
now peters has gone underground
reportedly hiding in a safe house
provided by mike lindell
after she allegedly participated in a
breach of mesa county voting machine
data this year
that data soon wound up on conspiracy
websites making peters a folk hero among
the maga set
and the subject of an fbi investigation
peters who did not return requests for
comment took office in 2019
after her predecessor reached the term
limit what followed was an unusually
bombastic tenure in a typically low
drama role
while overseeing the november 2019
general election peter's office forgot
to count 574 ballots leaving them
unattended in a drop box outside her
office for month that slip up coincided
with a rush of departures from peter's
office in december of 2019
nearly 20 of peter's 32-person staff had
departed
most more staff quit days after missing
ballots were discovered bringing the
departure count over two dozen
the colorado secretary of state's office
told peter to get her act together the
secretary of state's office appointed
someone to be in the clerk's office to
help with the election
patty in show a democrat and experienced
former mesa county clerk employee was
hired to help peters with elections but
just two months into ins cho's role
peters fired her accusing her of not
doing assigned work an allegation in
show denied the rift turned ugly peter's
staff were filing a criminal complaint
against in show for allegedly not
working during a pandemic
and the latest now
is that
peters reportedly is hiding out
in a um a house um rented or provided by
my pillow ceo mike lindell it it's it's
all just crazy and it's crazy on a few
fronts number one
the side that is regularly alleging the
voter fraud
seems to be the side regularly caught
alleged allegedly committing it and then
of course my mike pillow's involvement
in all of this just makes
such little sense we're going to try to
get more information about the story but
that's the latest as i understand it
right now
guys this voicemail is really depressing
uh here's a caller who called the
voicemail number yesterday 2192 david p
and he explains he's going to get
vaccinated but he didn't want to why
because his mom got a headache from the
vaccine listen to this
hey david how's it going so uh
i work at ohio university in ohio and
they just mandated the coronavirus
vaccine so it looks like i'm gonna have
to get it because
i don't want to be
poor and stupid so i'm going to get it i
guess what he means is it would be he
would lose his job and he needs money
the stupid part i don't know if he means
it would be stupid not to get vaccinated
or would be stupid to lose your job but
then listen to this
uh but i was holding off until now
because
my mom got it and she got very sick from
it uh
she had a really bad headache and uh
i just didn't want to go through that so
i was kind of putting it off because
what i didn't want to get it
my mom got very sick you know
so i'm just wondering what uh
what your opinions are about places that
are mandating the vaccine for people
that don't want to get it is what your
opinions are about that yeah i am
absolutely fine with the covet vaccine
being added to the list of required
vaccines if that's what an employer or
an organization wants to do
for kids to go to school there's been a
long list of necessary vaccines for a
very long time
vaccine requirements aren't new they're
just adding the now approved covet
vaccine to the list
but i'm really worried about a headache
uh you know i got a headache when i got
the vaccine i had a very you know mild
fever my arm hurt uh it was like one
night where i didn't feel well i felt
flu-like and then i was better and then
i was vaccinated
you would choose not to get the vaccine
to avoid one day of headache when it
reduces your risk of getting
hospitalized or dying from covid by more
than 90 percent
that doesn't make sense and that's
really really concerning to me uh and
i've heard it from others too i don't
know i heard but
i don't want my arm to hurt for a day
right but then you'll be vaccinated and
you'll be significantly protected
against hospitalization and death is it
don't you yeah but my arm i mean i don't
know my i might have a headache
we've got a real uphill battle here guys
real uphill battle but it sounds like
this guy's going to get the vaccine and
that's good we've got a great bonus show
for you today sign up at jointpakman.com
and get instant access
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman